ก็สวัสดีครับพี่เอ๋
สวัสดีค่ะน้องอาร์ตี้สวัสดีครับสวัสดี
ครับนักเรียนเย้ดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคนครับผม
วันนี้ช่วยกันอีกแล้วเอออ่าครัวตี้กับครู
พี่เอ๋เอ๋เอ๋
ได้ค่ะพี่เอ๋ขอพี่เอ๋ครูเอ๋ครูน้องเอ๋ไม่
ได้
ป้าเอ๋โอเค
โอเคอ่ะแฮปปี้ทำวันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วัน
นี้เรามา
เจอกันหาครับวันอีกวันนี้วันศุกร์ครับขอ
วันศุกร์วันศุกร์วันศุกร์ครับวันนี้ว่า
วันศุกร์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะสุขวันนี้วันที่
10 ครับ 5 ที่ 10 นะคะแล้ววันศุกร์วัน
ที่ 10 เนี่ยเดือนอะไรคะเดือนนี้ใช่ไหม
ครับเดือนนี้เดือน
ธันวาคมทัพ
หาเรื่องธันวาคมเดือนธันวาคมมีผชเท่าไหร่
คะมีนี้ปีพต
2564 ครับอ่าอีพศ
2564 ทรายผชเท่าไหร่คะปีคศ 2000  0  20
11 ครับ 5 น
21 หน้า 7
[เพลง]
เราเจอกันวันศุกร์
เวลากี่โมงเวลา
เวลาเวลากี่โมงเสือดาวโมงครับ
โมงอ่า 10 นาที
วันนี้เราเจอกันตอนตารางวันหาใช้ครับ
รางวัลวันนี้เป็นกลางวันได้ครับครู Arty
ไม่ไปออฟฟิศหรอคะขวดดีขวดติไม่ไปไม่ไปออก
ครับไหมทำไมคะ
วันนี้วันหยุด
วันหยุดทรายเฮาหยุดนะคะวันหยุดอ่ะก็ถึง
ออฟฟิศปิดอ่ะปิดไม่ไป
เป็ดไม่ไปออฟฟิศนะคะใจ
พูดครูเอ๋นายแล้วก็มาเจอกับ R ใส้ครับเจอ
กับครูโอเคครับแล้วว่าถ้าเรามีอะไร
ให้นักเรียนดูแล้วก็ฟังคะหน้าวันนี้มีมี
มีอะไรมีรถเข็นส้มตำนี้
รถเข็นอ่ะอ้าวตรงนี้เป็นรถเข็นอายมีล้อ
ด้วยใช่มั้ยใช่ครับติดล้อตรงนี้มีหรอหรอ
ใหญ่ถ่ายทอด 100 ไอ่มี 1 หรือ 2 ค่ะมีล้อ
ใหญ่สองล้อมีด้านนี้แล้วก็อยู่อีกท่านได้
เก่าอยู่ข้างหลังข้างหลังทรายข้างหลัง
แล้วก็มีร้อนเล็กๆ
มิดล้อเล็กๆอยู่ตรงนี้ล้อเล็กๆอยู่ด้าน
หน้าดอกนี้ 1 ร้อ
อ่าอันนี้เรียกว่ารถเข็นใช่ไหมคะได้ครับ
มีรถเข็นต้มตับรถเข็นอันนี้ขายส้มตำใช่
พูดรถเข็นส้มตำอ่ะถูกต้องที่รถเข็นมีผู้
หญิงใส่หมวกหาผู้หญิงตาๆเขาเราพูดว่าอะไร
คะผู้หญิงใส่หมวกคนนี้พูดว่าแม่ขาครับแม่
ค้า
คัดขายส้มตำก็พูดแม่ค้าส้มตำถูกต้องครับ
แต่มีผู้ชายด้วยใช่ไหมอ่ะมีผู้ชายถ้าเป็น
ผู้ชายขายขายส้มตำพูดว่าอะไรคะพูดว่าพ่อ
ค้านะพ่อขาส้มตำก็
นะครับผู้หญิงก็พูดแม่ค้าส้มตำใส่เขาชาย
พูดพ่อค้าส้มตำใช่ขับพระองค์ผู้หญิงใส่
หมวกนะ 5 ผู้หญิงกำลังทำ
คิดว่ามีถุงพลาสติกกำลังผูกผูกผูก
[เพลง]
ปู่
ถูกครับภาพ
ส้มตำไหมอ่ะอ่ะใช่กับครัวตี้คิดอะไรอ่ะ
หยุดว่าเป็นถุงส้มตำต้องเติมหรอบางทีพูด
ผูกบัญชีพูดรัฐเนาะรักๆๆรัฐถูกโอเครัดถุง
ส้มตำใต้ขับ
โอเคเอาหนังยางรัดอ่ะนะฮะอะรัก
ทิที่รถเข็นส้มตำมีอะไรอ่ะกูไอ้ตี้มาใกล้
ๆเนี่ยอยู่ตรงไหนก็ต้องนี้น้องมิต้องตรง
นั้นน่ะค่ะตรงนี้ตรงนี้เป็นเต่าเต่าย่าง
ครับเตาย่างๆขาวเป็นอะไรคะนี้เขาขาวๆตรง
นี้เป็นควันเป็นควันๆ
เต่ายาง
เขายังอะไรอ่ะกูอ่ะตี้
เขาย่างไก่ครับยังไก่ๆครับมีไก่ไก่คนไทย
เรียกไก่ย่างไก่ย่างๆครับ 5 ไก่ย่างไก่
ย่างนี่นี่มีคือใครอย่ามีไม้ไม้หนีบเอา
ไว้ 5 ใช่ครับมีไม้นี่หมายนี้ก็มีวิธีไม้
เสียบนะฮ่าๆๆไก่ย่างยางมาให้หาแล้วก็มี
มันมีควันหน้าเขต
หิวหิวไหมครับ 5 ตัว a หิวเป้เห็นแล้ว
น้ำลาย
หิวไก่ย่างไหมครับอยู่ไก่อย่างมิกไก่ 1
ตัวใช่ไหมคะอ่านี่ไก่หนึ่งตัวตรงนี้อ้ามี
ไก่ทั้งหมดกี่ตัวก็แนะหนึ่งตัวมีอะไร
1ตัว2ตัว3ตัวใช่กับพี่ไก่อาจจะ c มีตรง
อีกอ่ะอ่ะมองไม่เห็นอ่าเห็นนิดหน่อยไก่
ย่างๆครับน้ำดับอ่ะตัดตัดไหมคะมีครับมี
ครับมีเณรไก่ย่างไม่ซื้อ 1 ตัวฮ่าๆ
มีอะไรบ้างคะเนี่ยอันนี้นี้เป็นปีกปีกไก่
อ๋อปีกไก่ให้แล้วให้ใกล้ใกล้ๆปีกไก่ที่
มือมีมีมือผู้ชายตรงนี้ผู้ชายข้างล่าง
เป็นอะไรคะฮะอันนี้เป็น
ตับไก่ครับหน้าอ้าใช้ครับๆไก่ขยายด้วย
เนี่ยขยายนี้นี่ได้ครับ 5 นี่เป็นอ่างไก่
กับใจคือครับ
ผู้ชายถืออะไรอยู่คะอ้าผู้ชายถืออ่าเหล็ก
ยางไก่ใช้คีบๆที่น่ารักขี้พูดครีมฮะโอเค
อาหารบางทีพูดที่คีบค่ะขี้คีบไก่
นะคะ
แล้วก็มีมีเนื้อไก่ใช่ไหมข้างหลังถ่าย
ครับไก่อ้าเป็นเนื้อไก่นี่เนื้อตายเนื้อ
ไก่
โอ๊ยน่ากินอิ่มหน้าเดี๋ยวคลิปนี้เสร็จกู
เอ๋วิ่งวิ่งวิ่งไปข้างหน้าซื้อไก่ย่างห้า
วิ่งไปที่รถส้มตำใช่ไหมนี่ล่าหารถเข็นส้ม
ตำใกล้ๆคอนโดครูเอ๋มีรถเข็นส้มตำห้อใกล้ๆ
คอนโดกูเองมีรถเข็นส้มตำใกล้ๆบ้านอ่าครัว
ตี้ต้อมมีรถเข็นต้องต่ำเห็นส้มตอบนายให้
ครับมีปีกไก่น่าใช้ครับกไก่ห่าอะไรอีกอ่ะ
อ๋อไก่ตับๆอาหารอย่างอื่นไหมนาน R  R มี
มีอะไรอีกมีอันนี้เป็นปีกไก่นะครับที่น่า
นิยายอ้างเสร็จแล้วแล้วใช่ครับกิน in ได้
แล้วนะหิว
อามิปีไก่นะครับก็มีไม้แล้วก็เสียบๆครับ
ที่ใช้ไม้เสียบ
เราจะ
กินได้นายใช่ครับ
หน้ามีปีกตายแล้วก็มีมีที่รถเข็นมีอะไร
อีกคะ
ว่าอะไรคะหานี้เป็นน่องไก่น้องเก่าไก่ได้
ครับ 5 ไก่ก็จะมีมีมีไก่มีเดี๋ยวนะกลัวสิ
ว่าหัดไก่อ่ะ
ที่จ่าย 5 มีมีอ่าปีกใช่ไหมนะอ่ามีปี่
มีปี่
น่ารักไก่ก็จะมีมีขาด้วยหน้าตรงนี้ตรงนี้
น้องไก่ตรงนี้ครับ
น้องไก่
อยู่ตรงนี้อยู่ตรงนี้ไม่เห็นนักเรียนเห็น
ไหมไม่แน่ใจอ่ะอ่าอันนี้เป็นไก่โอเค
น้องไก่เห็นแล้วน้องกะอยู่ตรงนี้นี่ครับ
น้องไก่นี่นี้เลยน้องไก่
กู Arty ครับครูเอ๋เห็นที่ครูเอ๋ชอบใดๆ
น้องใจใช่ๆใช่ๆเห็นอื่นๆเป็น
ไก่ย่างเอกชอบคิดถึงไก่เหรอครับใช่ไม่
ชอบน่องไก่
ไม่ชอบปีกไก่อ๋อถึงอาชอบปีกไก่ชอบลิ้นไก่
แล้วกูเห็นชอบชอบอ่าอันนี้ไหมครับ
ก็เป็น
มาก
มีอะไรทำไม
ชอบมากเพราะว่าอร่อยอ๋ออร่อยใช่ไหมครับ
พรุ่งนี้กูเอชอบกว่าตีชอบมั้ยหัวตีชอบนิด
หน่อย verti ช็อปปี่ไก่มากกว่าปีกไก่นะไป
ชอบชอบตูดไก่คนไทยพูดกดตูดไก่
ตูดไก่
ครับตูดไก่อันดับหนึ่งเลยหอชอบหมาว่า
ร้านมาช็อปดูดไก่แล้วก็ชอบกินไก่ขอน้อม
กลิ่นกายกับตูดกา
อร่อยน่าจะไม่ดีนะไม่ดีกินมากๆไม่ดี
กินนิดหน่อยทีมนิดหน่อยอิ่มฮ่าๆๆอร่อยๆ
น้ำลายไหล
[เพลง]
โอเคที่รถเข็นส้มตำมีไก่อะไรอีกคะแล้วก็
มีมี
มีครับมีลาภกล้วยล่าครับ
ลาภลาภเป็นลาบหมูใช่ไหมหมายให้ๆนะโอ๋ๆเลย
อ่ะลาบหมู
แล้วมีอะไรอีกคะอ้ามีบนรถเข็นใช่ไหมครับ
หน้ามีไก่ย่างมาถึงแล้วก็มีอันนี้ครับตรง
นี้ตรงนี้เป็นตู้ออมีตู้อะไรครับสู้
ในตู้มีอะไรอ่ะในตู้มีมี
อ๋ออ้านี้ครับโอเคเห็นแต่เห็นนเห็นจัง
กว่าไหมคะใช่ครับนี่แตงกวาในตู้มีแตงกวา
แล้วก็มีอันนี้ด้วยครับก่อนสับที่หายเป็น
มากอกสับสับแล้วน่า
รักข้างบนคืออะไรข้างบนข้างบนตรงนี้เป็น
อ้ะสีแดงตรงนี้เป็นเมื่อเขือเทศ
หมด 5 อย่าแท้แล้วก็มีหน้าตรงนี้สีเขียว
เป็นมันหนาวไหมคะใช่แล้วอ่ะเปรี้ยวอ่ะ
เที่ยวถามน้าา
ดีนะครึ่งบนนี่เป็นผักผักอาหารอาเป็นผัก
เนี่ยพรุ่งนี้ตรงนี้ครับตรงนี้กูเห็นไหม
พรุ่งนี้จีนไหมอ่ะ
ใช่ไหมอะไรอ่ะนายให้ต้องตรงนี้เห็นแต่ไม่
ชัดอะไรอยู่ณตรงนี้กลัวตี้คิดว่ามันคือ
เราหัวหอมแดงหัวหอมแดงหัวใหญ่ไก่มากเลย
ครับ
แล้วก็มีข้างหลังอาจจะเป็นอาจจะเป็นผัก
แล้วก็มีขนมจีนทั่วอยู่ค่ะอ๋อข้างหลัง
เพราะล้านร้านส้มตำมีมากๆเนาะนายหัสนัย
ออกแล้วกู Arty  Oh มีผักอาจทั้งหมดพูด
ค่ะโอเคได้ครับผักมีผักมากๆครับ
กูเห็นน้ำปลาหมอ
ฮะโอเคมีทำ 5 อยู่ตรงนี้ใช่ไหมหาน้ำปลา
เมื่อกี้เห็นส้มตำใจครับพี่รถเข็นส้มตำ
เราสั่งสั่งแม่ค้าแม่ค้าส้มตำได้ว่าเนี่ย
แม่ค้าจะถามอะไรคะอ่าใช่ครับเราก็อะไรคะ
รับอะไรคะกินอะไรคะฮ่าๆๆนักเรียนมาประเทศ
ไทยเข็นรถเข็นส้มตำเดินเดินเข้าไปแล้วก็
มอง
แม่ค้าจะพูดใส่เหงาอะไรคะอ้าอะไรนะๆ
บางทีพูดเอาอะไรคะ
บางทีพูดรับอะไรคะกันชายชายขับหาแม่ค้าก็
จะพูด We
Are  in อะไรคะฮ่าๆ
ถ้าเป็นพ่อค้าพูดอะไรคะอ่ะพ่อค้าก็พูดกิน
อะไรครับ
เอาอะไรครับ 5 ไปเขาจะหมดอาร์ตี้มาเดินมา
แล้วพี่เอ๋แม่ค้า
กินอะไรคะก็กินไก่ย่างครับ
เอาปี่เอาน่องๆ
สูตรอา
อาอาขวดที่เอาปี่ครับเอาเอกไงปีกไก่กี่
ไม้เอาปีกไก่ 2 ไม้ในเอาปีบไก่ 2 ไม้ครับ
มีไม้เสียบไว้ใช่มั้ยต่อไม้ใช่ครับเอาไม้
อ่ะ
ดอกไม้
5 อะไรอ่ะหนึ่งปีกเท่าไหร่
หนึ่งเหตุใช่ไหมกลัวตี้ตัวตีคิดว่าหนึ่ง
อีก 10 บาทเหรอครับ
ซอยบ้านครูเอ๋
10 บาทขอ 10 บาทถูกถูกมั้ยฮะปาน
มันกู Arty กี่บาทบ้านขัวตี้โกตี้คิดว่า
20 บาท
แพ้
20 บาทโอ้วหาใช้ครับ
บ้านครูเอ๋ถูกมากๆถูกมาก
เคท่านครับอ่ะโอเคแม่ค้าจะถามเอาอะไรกู
Arty บอกเอา
ปีกไก่นะอ่าปีกไม้อะไร
จะเอาอะไรอีกกลัวตี้ก็ตอบว่าเอาส้มตำครับ
สมตำอะไรมาเอาส้มตำไทย 5 มีครับมิสต่ำไทย
เอาส้มตำไทยส้มตำไทยเผ็ดมั้ยเอาส้มตำไทย
เห็ดนิดหน่อยเผ็ดนิดหน่อย
สิเม็ดอ้ะเผ็ดนิดหน่อยใส่พริกใส่พริก 2
เม็ด
พริก 2 เม็ดนะอ่าใช่ครับพริก 2 เม็ดครับ
นะคะ
รอเดี๋ยวหน่อยต่ำตำส้มตำใช่ไหมครับน้า
คู๋คู๋คู่ S สั่งส้มตำคู่เอกสั่งเผ็ดไหม
ครับ
เผ็ดพอดีพอดีพอดีนี่เม็ดขอคู่เอกชอบ 3
เมตรใช่ไหมอ่าเม็ดหน้า Amaze แต่ครูเอ๋จะ
บอกตำไทยไม่ใส่กุ้ง
คู๋ไม่ไม่ใส่กุ้งได้ไหมครับไม่
ขอไม่ใส่ถั่ว
มัน
ไม่ตายได้ไหมคะไม่ใส่ถั่วถั่ว
นี้ใช่ไหมครับหรือกว่านี้
ถั่วถั่วลิสงถั่วถั่วคั่วขอถั่วคั่วนี้
ห่า Hey พวกไม่จ่ายไม่ใส่ถั่วคั่ว
S กินกุ้งไม่ได้กินกุ้งได้ตัวไม่ได้อ่า
อ๋อกลัวตี้ก็กินได้แวะไปที่
เมื่อก่อนกินโอเคตอนนี้กินแล้วคันหอกินใบ
กุ้งกับคันคำ
กินถั่วแล้ว
ปวดท้อง
ปวดท้องอ่ะถ้างั้นถ้างั้นไม่เอาตำไทยไม่
เอาตำไทยมีมีตามตำอะไร
ตำปลาร้าครับโอเคค่ะ
ตำปลาร้าไม่ใส่ถั่วถ้าไปครับขอตั้งปลุกตำ
ปลาร้าเดี๋ยวนี้เปิดร้านคืออะไรอ่ะำปลา
ร้าปลาร้าทำมาจากนี่ครับปลา
ๆ
สาธุๆครับ S ขอมครู Arty ผมขอไหมกลัวตี้
หอมได้ครับหอมดู Arty กับครูเอ๋เห็นปลา
ร้าคิดของหอมไส้เขาบางคนบ่เหม็นอายนัก
เรียนรู้คนเหม็นอ้า
ครูเอ๋ชอบปลาร้าก็
ไอครับหน้าแล้วขวดขวดข้างล่างคืออะไรคะ
อ่ะขวดข้างล่างเป็นปลาร้าแต่ไม่มีปลาไม่
มีปลามีแต่น้ำเป็นน้ำปลาร้าน้ำปลาร้านากู
Arty คะกู Arty ชอบกินส้มตำปลาร้าไหมคะ 5
ครัวตี้ Top กินส้มตำปลาร้าครับแล้วครู
ปาร์ตี้ชอบปลาร้าแบบเป็นน้ำปลาร้าหรือปลา
ร้าเป็นตัวปลาร้าขอปลาร้าเป็นน้ำถ้าพี่
ปฏิเสธมั้ยกินมั้ยกินปลาร้าเป็นตัวมาให้
ต่อ
ชอบทั้งสองอย่างอ๋อไปตีกินน้ำปลาร้าหา
กินได้ปลาร้าส์เป็นตัวปลาร้าอ่ะเป็นน้ำ
โอเค
[เพลง]
ส้มตำส้มตำปลาร้าใส่มะละกอ
r  b มีส้มตำที่ไม่ใส่มะละกอด้วยไม่ใส่
ไม่ใส่มะละกอใส่อะไรคะ 5 ใส่แตงกวาครับ 5
ใส่แตงกวานี่
เรียกอะไรคะอ้าคนไทยเลี่ยงตามแต่ aang
มีแต่แป้งใช่ครับต่ำใจมาร้าด้วยใช่ไหมใส่
ปลาร้าด้วยใส่ปิ๊กด้วยแตกแต่ไม่ใส่มะละกอ
แรงเป็นยังไงคะอ๋ออ๋อนี่ครับแตงกวาแตงกวา
ๆครับอ่าเปี้ยกตำแตงตำแตก
แต่งกว่า
มีอะไรอีกคะแล้วส้มตำกินกับอะไรอ่ะ 2 ห้อ
ไก่ย่างถามเผ็ดเผ็ดๆนะๆเผ็ดกินอะไรเผ็ด
เผ็ดเราก็กินกับข้าวเหนียวครับอ้ากินข้าว
เหนียวเขาซ้ายครับข้างบนข้าวเหนียวอยู่ใน
อะไรคะเขาเหนียวข้างบนอยู่ในถุงอยู่ในถุง
พลาสติกหน้า 1 พลาสติกใช้ครับแล้วข้าง
ล่างข้าวเหนียวอยู่ในมีอะไรหาข้างล่าง
ข้าวเหนียวอยู่ในกระติบนะคนไทยเรียก
กระติบใช้ครับในกระติ๊บอะติ๊ดชอบกินข้าว
เหนียวไหมคะน่ากลัวตีกินข้าวเหนียวกิน
ข้าวเหนียวกับส้มตำหน้า in ข้าวนี่
กับไก่ย่างด้วยผู้อัดดีชอบกินข้าวเหนียว
ครูเอ๋ไม่ชอบกินข้าวเหนียวอ่ะอ้าวกูเอ๋
ไม่กินข้าวเหนียวเอกกินอะไรครับอ่าคู่ a
ไม่ชอบว่ากินแล้วง่วงนอนเพราะเก๋ชอบกิน
ส้มตำกับขนมจีน
กับขนมจีนด้วยกันมีขนมจีนไหมคะมีขนมจีน
ครับนี่ขนม
ขนมจีนๆ
กินขนมจีนต่ำ
ที่เห็นแล้ว
ได้คิวแล้วหิวแล้วใช่ไหมครับอยากจะไปกิน
ส้มตำแล้วก็ขนมจีนอ๋อไก่
มีเยอะเลยนี่ที่รถเข็นส้มตำมีลายอย่างนะ
มีตั้มส้มตำไก่ย่างใช่ไหมครับน้าๆเดี๋ยว
นี่ไก่ย่างอ่ะมีส้มตำแล้วก็อยู่นะเมื่อ
กี้
ใช่ครับอ่ะกลัวตี้ลืมไปนอกจากนอกจากมี
ตำแตงตำแตงให้ครับมีตามถั่วด้วยควรตีชอบ
ชอบตำถั่วอ่ะนี้ครับภูวัว
หึโอเค
ริมเขื่อนเทศมะเขือเทศเขาไม่ใช่คลิกนะมี
พริกด้วยอยู่ตรงนี้อะมีพริกนิดหน่อยอ่า
ตัวอะไรคะเนี่ยหานี้มีถั่วฝักยาว
ถั่วฝักอ้าวนี่ครับแบบนี้ถั่วฝัก
ยาวได้งานยาวโอเค
เอาไปตำถั่วนะครับ
น่ากินกินใช่ไหมครับใช่
แล้ววันนี้ครูอันที่จะกินอันนี้ใช่คุณ
อาตี้ชอบตำตำถั่วตำแตง
หลับรักออยแล้วมะละกอเป็นยังไงอ่ะมะละกอ
ชุดที่ครับก็เป็นสับสับๆเสร็จแล้วมาต่อ
ที่สับแล้วจะเป็นเส้นแบบนี้แต่มะละกอที่
ยังไม่ทราบนี่เป็นแบบนี้ครับนี่มะละกอนะ
ครับส้มตำมะละกอนายครับนำมาละกอเรียกส้ม
ตำหน้าต่ำมีแตงกวาเบี้ยธตำแตงค่ะอ่าถ้า
ตามถั่วฝักยาวเรียกตามถ่วงถั่วๆๆตำใส่ปลา
ร้าเรียกถ้าต่ำถ้าตามใส่ป่ะล่ะที่อ่ะตำ
ปลาร้าครับนี่เอาน้ำ
เพื่อ
แต่ถ้าไม่ใส่ปลาร้า
ไม่ใส่ปลาร้าแล้วมีรสหวานมีรสหวานเรียก
ต่ำถ่าย
ต่ำไทยอาทิตย์ค่ำไทยไอมีรสหวานใช้ขามันก็
เผ็ดนิดหน่อยเนาะๆครับเผ็ดจะเผ็ดนิดหน่อย
ตำอราสจะเผ็ดมากๆได้ครับตำปลาร้าเผ็ดมาก
แล้วก็ใส่ปลาร้ามีร้อยเค็มเค็มชายครับตำ
ปลาร้าจะมีรสเค็มตำไทยจะมีหญ้าหวานหวานๆ
ได้ครับอามีแต่หิว
หิวแล้วพี่อยู่แล้วอ่ะคนไทยน่ะเห็นส้มตำ
แล้วก็โอ้ยหนูน้ำลายน้ำลายไหล High หลายๆ
หิวเลยครับ
กูอะติ๊กๆกินส้มตำ
บ่อยๆไหมคะอร่อยๆกินส้มตำไม่บ่อยไม่บ่อย
ใช่ครับหน้าอาทิตย์อาทิตย์จันทร์อังคาร
อาจเจ็บวันกินประมาณ 1 ครั้งหนึ่งอ๊อด 7
วันกิน 1 ครั้งให้เขาหาๆ
แล้วครูเอ๋กินบ่อยไหมครับพี่อยากกินส้มตำ
ต้องบอกว่า 1 ปี
1 ปี
กินประมาณ
3 ครั้ง 4 ครั้งหนึ่งปีกิน
3-4 ครั้งท้อท้อขวดที่ปวดอี้อี้ 1
อาทิตย์
อิ่มประมาณประมาณ 1 ครั้งครั้งหนึ่งครั้ง
เขตบางคนกิน
7 วันเลยกินทุกวันใช่ไหมครับจารย์ง่าย
วันพุธพฤหัสศุกร์เสาร์อาทิตย์กินทุกวัน
น๊า
นะคะวันนี้นักเรียนก็รู้จักรถเข็นส้มตำ
ครับอ่ะเอารถเข็นส้มตำมีอะไรที่รถเข็น
บ้างนะคะอ๋ออ๋อที่รถเข็นส้มทำมีอะไรบ้าง
ใช่ไหมครับ 5 นาทีรีวิวอีก 1  5  v  v  1
ครั้งบนรถเข็นก็จะมีไก่ย่าง 5 ยักษ์มี
อะไรอีกคะไก่ย่างแล้วก็มีมีตู้ตู้ใส่อ่ะ
ใส่ path นิสัย path ทรายครับๆอะไรอีกคะ 5
นักเรียนสามารถสั่งส้มตำได้สร้างตั้มไทย
หามีตำไทยสั่งตำปลาร้า
ได้ได้ครับ 5 สั่งต่ำแต่แตงได้แป้งไงครับ
แล้วก็สั่งตำถั่วได้ด้วย
แล้วก็มีเขียวเหนียวใช่นะมีข้าวเหนียวแต่
กูเอชอบคุยชอบขนมจีนจีนแล้วก็ชอบทกไก่วะ
ฮ่าตูดไก่กายอ่านมิลืมไม่ได้กูเห็นห้อง
ได้ตดไก่
อูอาตี้ช็อปน่องไก่ใช่กับไก่
โอเค
ยังมีเวลาไหมคะหรือหมดเวลาแล้วหมดเวลา
แล้วครับตอนนี้หมดแล้วใช่ไหม
งั้นคลิปนี้ครูเอกกับครู Arty ไปก่อนนะคะ
ไปกินส้มตำก่อนก็ตามก่อนแล้วกลับมาเจอกัน
ในช่องคอมเปลี่ยนสตัลไทยใหม่นะครับวันนี้
สวัสดีครับครูเอ๋สวัสดีค่ะคุณครับนัก
เรียนบ๊ายบายนักเรียนม